missions are things we tend to associate
with astronauts if someone at a party
asked what you did and you said you were
involved on a mission of some kind
people would look at you sort of
strangely but in truth we'd all benefit
from focusing in on the purpose of our
lives so that we can refer to them as
missions of one kind or another when the
entrepreneur Elon Musk was at university
he asked himself very explicitly what
his mission in life would be he began by
wondering what the world needed most
urgently then he looked into himself to
see what his talents were and that led
him to a list of four possible missions
space exploration electric
transportation artificial intelligence
and rewriting the human genome after a
bit more thought Elon Musk chose the
first too few of us will ever settle on
missions as mighty as these but the
notion of having a mission rather than a
mere job or a hobby remains widely
applicable how then can we learn to
adopt the mission mindset here are some
ideas firstly what matters is to adopt a
certain seriousness about one's life the
working bit will only be at best fifty
years so the challenge is around focus
how can one reduce the range of one's
enthusiasms and see that having so many
interests is half the problem talk of a
mission forces us to reduce what we care
about down to just a few very big things
it privileges precision overbreadth you
give yourself a specific target aware of
how much energy it will take to reach it
secondly a mission is about having a
plan and reducing the amount of times
that because one has no clear goal one
gets swept along by the plans of others
then again a mission is different from
an ambition an ambition starts with what
you want a mission centers around what
others need people with missions may
well end up making money and having
status but that isn't what led them to
the mission in the first place missions
are about the intrinsic worth of
they are about helping other people the
search for a mission requires you to ask
among all the problems facing humanity
what are the ones that properly interest
me be alive to a small scale but
authentic concerns you may have having
focused on a problem of humanity that
feels right for you you then need to
take an honest look at your own
aptitudes what truly are your talents
what can you contribute that may require
a lot of introspection career counseling
and experimentation then where your
skills and aptitudes intersect with the
needs of the world that is your
distinctive zone that is where your
mission lies a mission isn't a mission
because its grand but because its
precise examples of modest but crucial
missions might be a mission to improve
the care that the elderly receive at the
end of their lives or a mission to teach
children music in an engaging way or a
mission to get the best pizzas out to
the customers of north Liverpool or
downtown San Diego conceiving of a
mission requires us to throw off an
attitude of in a surf zone where we
imagine that only other people have the
right to plan their lives and everyone
else must just surrender to accidents
and the random whims of employers we can
and should all have missions with a
mission in hand the next time you're at
a party you won't need to keep the
conversation at the level of where
you're employed you can answer with
reference to the underlying logic of
what you're up to you can with no space
helmet to your name legitimately
announce that you're on this earth with
a mission to carry out
thank you for watching liking and
subscribing if you want more why not
visit us in person and attend a class or
take a look at our shop at the link on
your screen now
you